and welcome to Hannity tonight we are at
the end of a very busy day in the
Washington swamp in the Senate Democrats
they just confirmed a far left
Democratic activist to the Supreme Court
that is a lifetime position with the
help of of course Mitt Romney Lisa
murkowski uh the usuals of course in the
house covet positive Nancy Pelosi we do
wish her the best has been spreading the
virus apparently to everyone in sight
now look at this picture that's from
yesterday uh in the White House and yet
we have Biden's dishonest press
secretary jensaki circling back and
reportedly has a brand new well-paid
four gig at msdnc she'll fit in
perfectly most of their hosts lie so
that's set to begin in a few weeks but
of course she's still working as press
secretary and by the way NBC News
showing their High ethical standards
once again we'll get into that in a
minute but first more breaking news
tonight on Joe Biden's big lie in 2020
Biden repeatedly swore on equivocally
swore to the American people that he
never one time ever communicated with
his son or brother about their foreign
business Affairs or dealings Joe Biden
was lying not only did Biden discuss
these deals he was an active participant
in fact the New York Post just listed a
dozen times that Joe Biden played a role
in zero experience Hunter Biden's
International money making Ventures but
the first is Joe's letter of
recommendation we detailed this last
night not only did Joe write a letter of
recommendation for the son of Hunter's
Chinese business partner he also sent
the letter directly to the president of
Brown University and tonight we just
learned and we now know that Biden wrote
a second letter of recommendation for
the other child of Hunter's Chinese
business partner this time to Georgetown
University apparently neither got in so
much for the impact of a Biden
recommendation letter now Hunter also
acknowledged in 20 2019 in the New
Yorker that he and his dad once
discussed discussed Hunter's job on the
board of Barista Holdings so who's
telling the truth as Vice President Joe
was also introduced to at least one of
Hunter business partners during their
Six-Day trip together through Asia on
Air Force two that's when he met with
President XI and meanwhile in text
messages retrieved from zero experienced
Hunter's laptop from Hell well Hunter
Biden complained that he had to Fork
over half of his earnings to quote pop
and let's not forget about this picture
of the pair with Hunter's favorite
Kazakh oligarch that's the same oligarch
who said Hunter's company over a hundred
grand for a brand new sports car and
hear their picture together with Hunter
Biden's Mexican business partners in an
email Hunter complained to one Mexican
associate he hadn't received anything of
value after bringing quote every single
person you have ever asked me to bring
to the leaping White House and the vice
president's house and the inauguration
and by the way here are Joe and Hunter
golfing with Hunter Biden's main
business partner Devin Archer who also
served on the board of Barista Holdings
now Archer has been convicted of Fraud
and by the way he will soon be reporting
to prison Joe Biden also reportedly met
with Hunter's business other business
partner Tony bobolinski who has since
now identified Joe Biden as the big guy
as it appears on Hunter's laptop and is
set to receive a 10 payout from Hunter's
foreign deals in this case with the
Chinese Energy company now emails from
Hunter Biden's laptop in 2017 also
reveal Hunter was getting keys made to
an office for Jill Biden James Biden and
a Chinese executive named gong when dong
now Hunter is under a federal criminal
investigation for international money
laundering and tax evasion the Biden
Syndicate well they they may soon be
indicted a grand jury reportedly wants a
lot more information about who this big
guy is and about the big guy's 10
percent payout and of course other
monies received now could you just
imagine for a second if this will
president Trump and one of his kids a
media hysteria would be unlike anything
we have ever seen but during the 2020
election the media mob they refused to
report on any of this damning material
in fact they called the laptop Russian
disinformation remember this laptop came
out two weeks before the election and
remember big Tech Twitter Facebook they
absolutely banned anybody from even
sharing the information to decide for
themselves you may remember
Federal authorities are now
investigating whether recently published
emails that purport to detail the
business dealings of Joe Biden's son are
tied to an ongoing Russian
disinformation effort recently published
emails that purport to detail the
business dealings of Joe Biden's son are
actually part of an ongoing Russian
disinformation campaign Hunter Biden
this laptop the intelligence symbols
have warned or is quickly question
disinformation to me this is uh this
classic textbook Soviet Russian
tradecraft at work CNN reported on
Friday the U.S authorities are seeing if
those emails we just talked about are
connected to an ongoing Russian
disinformation effort
huh all right now that the election is
safely in the rear view mirror of the
laptop oh all of a sudden is now being
validated by multiple Outlets why did
that happen at this time could it be
that they knew the grand jury was asking
really important serious significant
questions and that they would be exposed
as the frauds they are I don't know call
me cynical don't expect them to correct
uh the record in any way don't expect an
apology that likely won't happen has
anyone ever corrected the record on all
their Russia collusion lies have they
corrected the record about all the
slander against Donald Trump and his
family now they know they buried this
Scandal they know they wanted to help
get Joe Biden elected and they're not
sorry about it and they're not going to
act sorry about it they'll just move on
to the next lie for example remember the
recent hysteria over the Trump phone
logs remember that this all turned out
to be false take a look
tonight 7 hours and 37 minutes missing
logs given to the January 6th committee
show that Gap in the former President's
phone records was there a burner phone
seven hours makes the 18 minutes of a
raised Oval Office tapes around
Watergate looked like a game of Patty
Cake a single call between 11 17 a.m and
66 54 PM that of course is the entire
window
of the Insurrection seems we need to
know who Donald Trump spoke to over that
missing 7 hours and 37 minutes and
crucially what they talked about
and why he wanted to hide it this
astonishing seven hour and 37 minute Gap
you and I go back to the uh
1970s and Watergate it was only an 18
and a half minute Gap
oh they're so excited they're giddy with
excite we got them it's just like water
Katie that's it we finally got them
the story was totally bogus none of that
rampant speculation on these fake news
networks turned out to be true but yet
again none of these media hacks ever
apologize or correct the record they
just move on to the next group of ice
this is why I've been saying since 2007
right here on this program journalism in
America is dead done gone and buried
make no mistake we have a major massive
information crisis in this country look
I'm not saying that they can't have
opinions what I'm saying is they need to
be honest like we are on this program am
I a member of the press yeah obviously
I'm a member of the press I am a talk
show host I tell you what I do for a
living I can produce thousands of hours
of radio and TV of me providing straight
news no opinion we've done investigative
reporting uh Barack Obama's radical
associations the Trump Russia collusion
lie narrative we spent three years on
that with investigative reporting I'm up
front I'm a conservative I offer my
opinions I tell you candidates I like
and candidates I don't like we do
cultural issues we do Sports this this
show is like an entire newspaper we do
it all the difference is they claim that
they're objective and fair and balanced
and that they're journalists they're not
scientists tell them but they just talk
to your hosts with opinions like me
except they lie and claim to be
something they're not listen to One
Atlantic reporter I had a very ironic
disinformation conference on Wednesday
listen to this
do you think the media acted
inappropriately when they instantly
dismissed uh Hunter Biden's laptop as
Russian disinformation and what can we
learn from that and ensuring that what
we label is this information is truly
this information and not reality my
problem with Hunter Biden's laptop is I
think totally irrelevant I mean it's not
whether it's disinformation or I mean I
didn't think the hunter Biden's business
relationships have anything to do with
who should be president of the United
States so I didn't I don't find it to be
interesting I mean that that would be my
problem with that as a major news story
now this might be my favorite not to be
outdone make-believe journalists
full-time Fox and Hannity stalker Humpty
Dumpty referred to valid criticism of
fake news CNN as a vast right-wing
conspiracy noticed that he never will
answer the question that the student is
rightly asking about how abusively
corrupt and abusively biased fake news
CNN is take a look
they pushed the Russian collusion hoax
they pushed the Jesse Smollett hoax they
smear Justice Kavanaugh as a rapist and
they also smeared Nick salmon as a white
supremacist and yes they dismissed the
hunter Biden laptop Affair as pure
Russian disinformation with mainstream
corporate journalists becoming little
more than apologists and cheerleaders
for the regime is it time to finally
declare that the uh the Canon of
journalistic Ethics is dead or no longer
operative all the mistakes of the
mainstream media and CNN in particular
seem to magically all go in one
direction are we expected to believe
that this is all just some sort of
random coincidence or is there something
else behind it
too bad it's time for lunch you have 30
seconds no I mean there's there's a
clock that says 30 seconds but but I
think my honest answer to you and I'll
come over and talk in more detail after
this is that I think you're describing a
different Channel than the one that I
watch uh but I understand that that is a
popular right-wing narrative about CNN
that student was a thousand percent
right on every issue fake news CNN got
wrong and little Humpty Dumpty Ollie sat
on a wall and he had a great fall and he
couldn't answer the question uh never
forget the Russia collusion was three
years of conspiracy theories and lies
and a hoax what he said about Justice
Kavanaugh uh was true and he wasn't a
rapist fake news CNN ended up paying
high school student Nick Nicholas
Sandman a ton of money after they
viciously smeared him on their network
uh that's not a right-wing narrative
Humpty that's called a fact something
you don't know anything about which
brings us to msdnc now according to
reports current White House Press
Secretary Jen saki Circle back will soon
be on the peacock Network apparently
some NBC staffers and news people say
they're worried that this partisan hire
could taint the Network's Sterling
reputation uh you think you have a
sterling reputation you're are living in
Mars This is the same network that
employs Democratic activist Chuck Todd
the same network that features Russia
collusion truthers like Rachel Maddow
and Lawrence O'Donnell and everybody
else on msdnc they lie to their viewers
day and night 24 7. so I think actually
jensakio probably fit in perfectly there
after all she is a notorious liar and we
have the tape to prove it take a look
you may have noticed this week that your
gas prices have gone up I want to talk
to you a little bit about why a lot of
it has to do with Vladimir Putin
it's broadly known and widely known
Peter that there was a broad range of
Russian disinformation back in 2020. why
is the administration flying thousands
of migrants from the border to Florida
and New York in the middle of the night
uh well I'm not sure that it's in the
middle of the night as individuals come
across the border and they are both
assessed for whether they have any
symptoms if they have symptoms they are
the intention is for them to be
quarantined that is our process they're
not intending to stay here for a lengthy
period of time it won't be there for a
period of time because they're going to
put them on an airplane and fly them to
the state of their choice now whether
sock is behind the podium in the
briefing room or in front of a camera on
msdnc she'll be doing the same thing
lying for a living hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else